[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
it's lit it's always lit it's always lit
my babies dude what's up hi guys
whoops hit it by mistake the oops button
hit it even by mistake starting it out
with a mistake not even a mistake a
mistake was hitting the thing
how crazy is that the mistake was
hitting the oops button and the oops
button made the [ __ ] sound that it
should have made when i made mistake uh
when they made the mistake when the
mistake was the mistake it's like a
[ __ ] crazy chris nolan movie but
whatever dude um
let's do some you know what we got do we
uh we we what we're doing today is
uh first before we get into it before we
get into it we're doing today we're
going to where is crystalia going to be
on the road you go to chrisleya.com to
get your tickets chrisley.com
to get your tickets is grand prairie
texas which is right outside of dallas
if you're in dallas you get to grand
prairie texas august 26th if you go get
tickets in august 26 those tickets are
flying so uh go and get the good tickets
it is going to be the next day august
27th it's going to be a witch at all
with which it taught which dog kansas
for some reason that's where the btk
killer is the bbtk killer was there were
a lot of killers in wichita kansas and
that's where chrisley is going to be
august 27th
uh wichita kansas has a sordid pass when
it comes to serial killers when it comes
to serial kill killers
ptk
and then atlanta we're gonna be
definitely a lot of murders in atlanta
too because it's atlanta september 9th
so many murders and chrisley is going to
be there september 9th washington d.c
politically motivated murder murders
september 10th
a lot of political assassin
assassinations uh going to be in
washington dc september 10th stockton
and oakland well you know what's what
stock stock stockton and oakland lots of
lots of [ __ ] murders lots lots of
getting your dome split by bullets but
chrisley is doing the murder tour
september 23rd and 24th coming at you
stockton california and oakland it's
absolutely [ __ ] dangerous when it
comes to bullets
peoria and rockford illinois no clue if
it's dangerous but it's right near
chicago so it probably probably it
[Laughter]
so it probably is probably chicago is a
hotbed for getting your wig pushed back
playa rockford illinois and peoria right
outside right right outside of chicago
go to grizzly.com for tickets might you
might might get shot raleigh north
carolina no north carolina can be in
raleigh north carolina october 21st
north carolina that's where that dude
pushed his [ __ ] down the stairs
staircase raleigh north carolina maybe
not bullets but also the dude [ __ ]
absolutely committed capcap capital
murder on his wife and then savannah
georgia it's actually really nice got a
lot of horses and [ __ ] farm life so
october 22nd i'll be in savannah georgia
and then denver colorado which is
november 5th which is a lot of weed a
lot of really cool nice stuff going on
cheyenne wyoming beautiful beautiful
mountains november 6 and then boston
massachusetts boston boston no stranger
to getting killed november 12 november
12th two shows at the boston at the wang
theater no
no no [ __ ] stranger to getting your
wig wig wig pushed back play huh and
lakeland florida a lot of crazy [ __ ]
happens in florida like like getting
your wig pushed back and also in an
incest and incest and and then
jacksonville
incest incest and also getting your wig
wig pushback december second and third
dude so [ __ ] it's the
murder tour of america chrisley.com so
go over there i don't even know if you
heard any of the cities because of the
bid i was doing but you know trying to
push tickets and [ __ ] all those areas
so go to chrisley.gracilia.com
anyway dude wow i do bits so long and
it's so annoying and i get it and my son
does it too basically what i'm saying is
i'm a child so sue me i'm a child i do
those things i do those things i do bits
that take so long and my son loves those
bits and he doesn't even say again daddy
again you know how kids go again daddy
again again again i don't even have to
say that because i'm already doing it
because i do it and it takes so [ __ ]
because i love doing bits so long i love
doing a bit so long and i'll keep doing
the bit so long so dude he's got the
best dad when it comes to again daddy
okay
um
but i love doing it we do lots of crazy
bits me and my me and my son and my
son's a [ __ ] stud dude love him so
much uh
yeah dude
it's different now your boy got married
um and that's that's what happened this
week so [ __ ] yeah dude before i get into
that i'm wearing the new join our cult
and share ideas merch crystalia dot com
chrisley.com wear this and go to go go
to [ __ ] atlanta get you get your wig
pushed back um get your get your wig
push back playboy
and so um
anyway i got married dude so that's
what's up dude
so that's what's up man
hell yeah dude and it was a beautiful
ceremony was out in santa barbara still
drinking the [ __ ] water from the the
dude brought up waters
you call a [ __ ] place down there and
you're like can we get some waters
they'll be like where do you get can we
get room service in the [ __ ] in santa
barbara they're like sorry everything
closes at 4 00 p.m
everyone here has dinner at 3 30 because
you have to be [ __ ] a gajillionaire
to live there because there's so many
[ __ ] republicans dude if you're
republican and you live in la you go to
santa barbara after you turn 60 and you
[ __ ]
and you get a place that's super nice
and it's a quiet sleepy town but it's
beautiful dude and all the buildings
look the same because you know you're in
a nice town when all the [ __ ]
buildings look the same right because
everything has to be to code
right if you do a place if you're at a
place where where all the buildings are
set are the same you gotta [ __ ] do it
to code and doing stuff to code is
completely annoying especially because
times change and beautiful and and
things that are beautiful change right
but
the the code and the town they don't
give a [ __ ] dude especially if they're
old and white they're like you ain't
changing [ __ ] that's too new that's too
new for this city so we were in santa
barbara and i tried to get a [ __ ]
room service and they were like no and i
was like can i just get four waters and
they're like sure and they brought up a
whole case and he was like you want more
mr dalia and i was like sure so he gave
me a whole case so now we got these
waters we're just drinking these [ __ ]
waters from hotel california
it's a lovely place
it's a lovely place
welcome to it's actually [ __ ]
it's pretty silly to call it the hotel
californian when there's a huge song
called the hotel california but whatever
just added an end to it
um
yeah so uh it's like [ __ ] naming your
motel the look
in with [ __ ] three ends um
so worst joke of all time so um all good
but it's all good
get your head out your ass playboy
[Laughter]
dude so we went to that [ __ ] sleepy
town and we got married dude and
everyone was so beautiful there and my
son was there he was so beautiful he had
a bow tie on it it was cute as [ __ ] and
he was saying cheese for all the
pictures it was so [ __ ] nice man
and i'm just happy dude i'm happy to be
[ __ ]
you know hitched or whatever they call
it uh
and um i don't know man it's uh i talked
a little bit about it on the king and
the stick in the wing but uh it was just
cool man um
was i nervous was i anxious anxious
maybe you know a little bit of anxiety
uh just having everything go according
to plan have it be nice as [ __ ] a lot of
people are coming making the trip out
you know uh and uh but it's really nice
to have friends there and support man
shout out to a lot of people that
[ __ ] were there um it was really nice
to see all of them a lot of dancing a
lot of beautiful stuffs going on and uh
had a great band i forget the name of
them of course like a piece of [ __ ] hey
what's the name of the band
great um
and i'll find it and i'll [ __ ] put it
up but dude they were well you know we
paid for them a [ __ ] arm and a leg so
um
what's the name of the
band the cowling band because the guy's
cowling last name is cowling
cowling yeah got it cool awesome and so
uh so that's the name of the band and
dude the band was [ __ ] it ripped the
band ripped the band ripped they sang
songs dude
that were just like the [ __ ] that were
just like the [ __ ]
that came out when it came out they were
just like do you remember
in september and that's just me without
warming up but these guys i don't even
think they needed to warm up either but
the cool thing about the band was that
they were so good all of them had all
sorts of [ __ ] different instruments
that they were playing they were doing a
guitar a violin a guy was singing and
doing a lot of spinning and then hitting
the mic and singing and then he would
spin again and [ __ ] come back again
dude and it was like three hours until
they played shout so they were a good
wedding band because they were doing so
many songs before they're like all right
we got to get the shout then they played
shout and then i went gotta leave hit
the doorway but they were so good that i
was like you know what they're actually
kind of killing shout and i went back in
there isn't a whiter song than shout
dude when they get a little bit quiet
and [ __ ] [ __ ] all that
uh
and uh
but dude the guy the lead singer of the
cowling band my god dude
we we picked him because we picked that
band because of that guy when krista was
showing me the links of bands
i saw a picture of the guy and i go i
don't need to see anyone else that guy's
the wedding singer dude because
of how he looks
you know
and guess what
your boy was right is he a pre-cog is he
psychic because the dude came
came through
and [ __ ] flamed the area
it flamed the area we had a beautiful
let me get before we even get to the
dude we had a beautiful ceremony it was
out on the [ __ ] roof you know if a
ceremony is out on the roof forget it
dude
so nice the views crazy nice the views
of the beach and even if you look back
in the other direction you couldn't even
see a parking lot that's how nice it was
dude views in every direction were nice
dude like an orgy it was unreal
they're probably some bad views and
orgies to be honest is that frank's
[ __ ]
um but yeah dude it was like an orgy
view with no frank's [ __ ] and um
who knows a guy named frank anyway
especially an orgy dude
a guy named franken and orgy would be
just a [ __ ] okay frank just with a
cigar [ __ ] ashen out on other dudes
um
so uh the ceremony was beautiful valves
were nice we wrote them was nervous went
off without a hitch had some mic issues
it was all good fell back into my
[ __ ]
i did some crowd work material at my own
wedding right asked the guy where he was
from kidding well actually did but as a
joke
and um the vows were great got through
him didn't even cry
close to as much as eric griffin
[ __ ] yeah dude
eric griffin cried so much at his
wedding and i cried medium amount
[Music]
hell yeah dude because why because i
practiced dude i
practiced i wrote it in my notes and
then i practiced and i thought maybe i
wouldn't read it but then the [ __ ]
the lady printed it out and i read it
and it was still nice dude
heartfelty [ __ ] dude
so um
not a dry eye in the audience
except for cooper cooper was there
our dog and uh calvin uh was actually
not the one who cried the least probably
at the wedding he was just literally
just
at one point we were in the middle of it
and we said do you want to come up and
he goes like this no thanks
and everyone was just
weddings are good audiences dude
they just
think right everyone laughs all you
gotta do in the vows is be like and i
promise to try and love chocolate chips
as much as you do too and the audience
was like
though he does like chocolate chips
that's one of his things
and i even promise to try and be a
little more patient when i teach you
origami
[Laughter]
but yeah i do it
we killed it had some mic issues
and uh
it was all good though we got it on
video
and uh
the mic went out but it was cool because
we used the what do you call the
efficience mike and i and kristen was
holding it and then i was holding her
vows because she has only two hands yeah
go figure i married a check with only
two hands
and um
so it was cool and then i have one of my
friends that [ __ ] like everyone was
like okay go ahead and make down to the
reception and then i have my gangster
friend i have one gangster friend that's
like
no matter what dude his name is sam and
he's [ __ ] persian and no matter what
he [ __ ] hangs back you know he's like
one of those guys that's like i'll hang
back for you dawg you know
and everyone went to the reception and
he didn't and he was just like holding a
bag which is wasn't his he's always
carrying something for some [ __ ] he's
like i take care of my people you know
and like and like we have the family was
taking pictures and [ __ ] and sam was
just watching lurkin and like he's one
of my best friends but if you didn't
know that you'd be like who the [ __ ] is
this guy with the long hair just staring
at and that sam and someone's like you
good you're good dog you're good
and then it'd be like yeah and be like
okay you want me to hang back nah just
go to the reception man
no nobody's gonna [ __ ] what do you
think who do you think is coming the
crips
okay dog
and then he walks down and has a
reception and oh dude i met sam when i
was in high school and we were in summer
school and dude the guy told so many
stories and every story he told
ended with someone stealing a car dude
and i would be like dude you know how
many stories you tell where the [ __ ]
guy steals a car
and he laughed so hard and we [ __ ]
made friends do it and he was a bully
now he's not a bully anymore he's
reformed dude he's a good guy i [ __ ]
love that dude
um
sam chic baby uh so yeah he's the
[ __ ] good dude always wears black
calls us caravan perella unbelievable
dude i have the weirdest friends it's
unbelievable and i love them all
and he showed up to support
everyone was there you know [ __ ] had
people that we loved was there [ __ ]
eric griffin bobby lee the [ __ ] uh uh
brendan schaub they were all there it
was a [ __ ] love fest dude
um
mike linochie crushed a speech it was a
funny funny as [ __ ]
too bad he can't put it on his [ __ ]
tick tock because it's personal uh but
that he would rake the views up dude but
that [ __ ] was hilarious he did the
speech my brother did a speech it was
beautiful even though my brother dressed
like a dick tracy character
um but yeah it was awesome man it was
awesome
my brother dick tracy character [ __ ]
mustache pinkerton or some [ __ ] and uh
mustache maroon
that wow that would
that would be yeah
we got to get dick trace yeah mustache
maroon because he had a mustache and
only wore maroon and had a shirt on that
said powered by dreams at a wedding
and so uh and it said it so many
different times and had a mustache and a
little bob's burger haircut dude it was
unbelievable and so um
so anyway dude my brother killed it i
love everybody i love everybody man um
adam ray [ __ ] so many good people ian
edwards my friend gavin from childhood
you got no you got no i dare who that is
and it's fine he's a wrestling coach
and um
yeah dude
killed it had a good time and the
wedding singer did let's get back to the
wedding thing you're good this guy first
of all oh walks up to me before the
dinner drops and i'm like why right
because the band isn't playing yet we
just [ __ ] all got done crying we sat
down at the long table because we sit
with our friends we don't do that
[ __ ] [ __ ] honeymoon table what do
they call it a [ __ ] the table with
it's just it's where you're like you're
like it's just you and the bride like
game of thrones and like we're always
with each other what the [ __ ] is this it
looks like somebody's gonna go like this
and somebody's just gonna slit someone's
throat yes that's what we do at our
wedding
we sit together and
and make sure that we are the [ __ ]
king that's [ __ ] if you do that you
sit with your friends dude you're here
with your friends it's a love fest
so um
and eric [ __ ] did it with his bride
he [ __ ] up dude i'm telling you you
want to sit with your friends man and uh
so we sat and we were sitting down and
all of a sudden i get a tap on my
shoulder and there he is the [ __ ]
leader the cowlings band
he says hey man dude i just and i knew
it i knew that's how he was gonna
[ __ ] sound because of his face
sometimes you just guess and you know
right when i was a kid i used to have
this feeling that i thought i would be
able to predict who the next person i
was gonna see in my life was oh dude i
am crazy but i had this strong feeling
like a very strong feeling that the next
person i saw when i was out whether i
was at a mall or turned a corner or
whatever that i should be able to see
and know what he was going to look like
and of course i never did it but i
always tried but voices i'm good dude
one guy one time a guy walked in a room
uh and i was at ccd communicate
community communion and i was with my
brother and uh and he came in and i was
like oh that guy's gonna sound like this
and i did his voice and then he [ __ ]
started talking i was like dude i knew
him i was like how do you do that and i
go like this i got powers man i got
powers
so um
so the guy came in and started talking
and he was like dude i just want to say
how happy i am to be here and i was like
oh he's one of these positive guys right
like he's got to be one of these [ __ ]
yoga dudes he's got to be one of these
guys who eats a lot of granola does yoga
always is positive and probably i'm not
saying he did i have no idea but
probably has bad breath right like guys
who are super positive and do yoga if
you don't have bad breath something's
seriously wrong with you you're not
doing it right right you got to have bad
breath if you do yoga and you're always
positive right
so um
so he comes up and he's just like dude
i'm so happy to be here man he's one of
these 55 year olds one of these 50 year
olds that talk says dude a lot you know
and uh i'm so great this is such a
beautiful time uh in in life and you're
you're getting married and uh i'm so
happy you hired us is there anything
that we can do that we can sing for you
guys that you'd like and i said oh dude
well we we saw your video and your demo
reel it and you killed it it's amazing
this is why we hired you i didn't tell
him we hired him because his face cause
you're obviously a wedding singer and
this is the guy i want singing at my
wedding because of his face
because of the aesthetic of his face
right
this guy goes move over adam sandler
with jerry curl i'll do it
right
so um i say you should it kills you guys
are great just do what you do and he
said oh really you sure we could do a
sort of mix of stuff and normally what
we do is classic rock we play the
classics if that's cool and i was like
absolutely and he was like so you don't
want anything specific you don't want to
lead me in a certain direction and i was
like nah dude you do you it's why we
hired you and that's something i believe
in dude it's something i believe in we
had a wedding planner and she said we
were the easiest couple that she ever
[ __ ] worked with
because you delegate right we delegate
my babies we're all about delegation
that's why when you join the cult and
you share ideas what do you do dude
everyone has a [ __ ] thing to do in
the tall grass or they're working on the
cabin they're putting out wheats
trimming some [ __ ] hanging up curtains
we gotta live baby
but we're all about delegating
this is delegating central right
and uh
so we're so so i say you do you and he
says all right well if you change your
mind if you think anything i'm your guy
just come to me and i go all right cool
and then he walks away and i see my
beautiful bride so i say hey you know
what guy who has that face why don't you
ask her she's she would know and i see
him
and then kristen just goes like this
and he's like
and she goes
and he goes like this
and then walks away right
so i'm like all right he's just gonna
play the hits he's gonna do what we saw
in the video all right
so we get to dancing by the way the food
was spectacular and you should just you
sh they didn't i feel bad for the people
who were like this food it's great i was
like you you didn't [ __ ] get to taste
what we cut you didn't even get to taste
what we didn't use
for the tasting dude we had some crazy
chicken that didn't even make the cut
dude
dude we've got chicken with all sorts of
nice drizzle on it that we tasted that
didn't even make the cut enjoy your
short ribs though
enjoy your salmon with pharaoh
enjoy the tortellini risotto what the
[ __ ] i don't even remember at this point
but i got the short ribs
and uh
if you by the way a short rubs are on a
menu you get the short ribs dude that's
just how it goes man okay
so
we eat the [ __ ] was really good gave the
speeches
um
mike linochie was funnier i wish he was
that funny for people when he opened for
me um
you know uh chris's mom did a great
speech she used to be a newscaster
a newscaster and she killed it everyone
was like she really know and i would be
like she's a newscaster and okay that
makes sense
she ended with she started the speech
with tonight at 11 and um
is broccoli bad for you
kristen and chris met so um
then we start we go into the [ __ ]
room that was all done up nice it was
beautiful right
uh i shared some images on my instagram
but um chris leah
and uh we get there the band is in full
swing and
they are just [ __ ] killing it dude
flaming it up right okay
and so the guy's singing and oh he's
singing with his face just doing his
[ __ ] thing just killing it doing all
sorts of great songs songs where i'm
like well i even thought of that but
then okay okay yeah very cool
and um
the first set ends you know he does like
a 40-minute set or whatever it is he
said we're gonna come back for another
set we're gonna take a little break
he comes back
i'm [ __ ] talking and [ __ ] the music's
playing and all that [ __ ] i gotta tap on
my shoulder
who is it dude
it's the [ __ ] wedding singer and he
says hey man and i said hey he's like
dude i'm so happy i'm here and this is
great isn't it and i said yeah he said
dude is there anything that you want me
to sing for you and i was like oh man
dude honestly this night is going
spectacular and i'm just [ __ ] love
what you're doing he says all right
because if you want me to do any certain
things i mean you can give me a few
songs or whatever and i could play them
we know everything and i was like dude
honestly no notes you're killing it
everyone's having a good time i don't
want to interfere with it so please just
continue to do what you're doing and he
goes like this ah all right man well let
me know if you change your mind and i
said okay cool he puts his [ __ ] ear
things back in and he goes and kills
another set yes dude everyone's having a
good time the cotton candy swirl is
happening the [ __ ] life rips coffee
shop is having and yeah i had that that
was a surprise for kristen i had no idea
but there was a coffee spot with a sign
that said life rips coffee [ __ ] was
awesome dude we had little [ __ ] uh uh
uh fried chicken shits even my old
manager was there just like oh you know
i was chicken in there like it was just
a [ __ ] love fest right
yeah look i'm so happy i'm here you know
be invited you know it's not like i
don't
know
in there all right
so
oh killer merch did the life rips thing
shout out to killer merced do the merch
right cool
um and so that's very cool i didn't know
that so um
anyway
uh
so so now
they do another set and they kill it
dude this band they take [ __ ] you you
heard about spin moves in the first set
dude this guy was spinning so hard
he looked shorter by the end of the
second set because he was drilling a
hole into the ground dude this guy was
now just [ __ ] he looked short he was
like a con out there just [ __ ]
convict music
getting [ __ ] small as [ __ ] dude
shout out to the old episode where i
made fun of akon he should be short
because of the [ __ ] voice he has
anyway dude for all the true babies they
know that [ __ ]
so does another set dude and this
[ __ ] they i thought the first set was
good and they were just
firing right
that said and we're gonna take a break
because i was like three hours into the
[ __ ]
uh
dancing
i get a tap on my shoulder and i'm by
the by this time i'm sitting down my
legs are done like you know when you're
just working on adrenaline in vivance
and you're just like oh okay cool i had
no idea that my legs were moving this
much so long and now i gotta just take a
[ __ ] seat and you sit down to
somebody you barely know and they're
just like so
is it hard what you do and you're like
oh here we go
what do you mean dude it's not brain
surgery but
so uh how do i if i wanted to get into
stand-up i you're 50. and so
so
i
who comes up to me the [ __ ] wedding
singer and this is three hours into him
already singing i mean the guy is
crushing it right and he says oh man
this is just great what a vibe i'm so
happy i'm here and i'm like
still okay
but i get it
and he's like
sure enough says you know what he's
gonna say but he actually says again for
the third time
is there anything you want me to play
and i'm like this guy
he really wants a suggestion okay but i
don't know
i'm not even i don't know what he played
or what he didn't play
so i say you know what man
i know you keep asking but you're
killing it i don't want to get in your
way of the [ __ ] you're just
on this mode of
absolutely everyone's having a good time
play whatever it is that you got if you
got more [ __ ] you want to play keep
doing it do whatever you want and he
says are you sure man i mean it's been a
whole night and like if you want you
could tell now i'm like does this guy
think i'm like lying to him like i do
have a secret song that i want him to
play
that maybe i'm not saying because i'm
bashful
i'm not bashful
he should know i'm not bashful
i mean he's definitely googled me and
knows what i do hope he didn't google me
but like
so i'm like he's like are you sure
there's nothing and and i'm like all
right you know what dude it's been three
times
so now you win
you win
i'm gonna say a song
because everything's going right now
here in my head i'm gonna say a song
he's gonna say we don't know if we know
that oh okay and then he's gonna [ __ ] it
it's gonna be my fault right but i'm
like the guy's come up to me three times
the night's almost over
so i say
okay
brick house
i haven't thought
of the song
brick house
since i first saw pulp fiction and brick
house was on in the background of one of
the scenes
okay i mean i haven't thought of the
song
brick house
in decades
i don't know where i pulled this [ __ ]
title brick house out of
but i do like the song and that's where
my mind went so i said to the guy
brick house
and this is what he does now i gotta
stand up because this is what he did
this is what he did he he goes like this
i know you can't see me in my body but
this is what he does this is what he
does he goes like this
he goes like this
man
[Applause]
oh
man
that is great i am just so
happy i'm here thank you for having me
and i say
yeah man i'm really happy you're here
and he starts to walk away and as he's
walking away
he says
it feels so
good
why
what does okay he says it feels so good
and walks away so i was like man i
really nailed the suggestion
they do their set they play for another
hour the guy never [ __ ] played brick
house
the whole time you didn't play brick i
still live in her brick house now i
still haven't heard brick house
the guy [ __ ] asked me three times
monopolizing my conversation i'm giving
him my energy please please tell me a
song i finally pulled out brick house
because i heard it once in [ __ ] 1992
and the guy [ __ ] looked like he was
about to struck me off with pride
and then didn't [ __ ] play it
how can you be like that
that guy
is my [ __ ] hero dude that is unreal
to do that
i love this dude god i would [ __ ]
hang out with that dude so much he yeah
dude i i feel so bad that i already had
my wedding i would invite him to my
wedding
to be in the [ __ ]
in the actual
wedding party like we didn't have best
men or whatever we just had my best man
calvin
my son's really serious bro he's just
[ __ ] so serious that's how i was eric
griffin was like your son is so serious
and i was like hell yeah dude he's just
always trying to figure [ __ ] out man
my son's always trying to figure out
figure [ __ ] out
um
and then we had a good time in and we
were uh
we went to another bar at the end
my dad was drunk i haven't seen my dad
drunk that drunk in a long time
everybody was drunk man people were on
ma was on molly i don't even know how
the [ __ ] where did where to get molly
some guy just [ __ ] came and was
throwing molly in people's mouths and
[ __ ]
um shrooms
everyone did heroin though and um
meth my dad was on ayahuasca and um no
and so uh so then we were like all right
let's keep going let's keep partying so
everyone walked down the street
um
and uh we went to another bar
and we were in this bar like this
dueling piano bar it's a [ __ ] dueling
piano places you know have hate places
have one piano have one piano or no
piano you need two there's some places
out there with [ __ ] no pianos you got
two [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] place
so we're in there and
you know
sam's there and he's like you want me to
go in and scope the place out first make
sure everything's cool i'm like bro it's
fine you know all right let me give
these things to this other person i'm
holding
and um
so we get to the [ __ ]
uh
dueling piano place
and we're hanging out having a good time
and we and i gotta go pee
so i go i walk over to the [ __ ]
bathroom and i'm not one of those [ __ ]
asses that's like where's the bathroom i
look for it first
okay do you guys it's you know what it
is it's in the [ __ ] back
you know why because the toilet's never
in front because of shed and pests
if i worked at a restaurant and somebody
was like where's the bathroom i would
say i would get fi
figure
you guess
oh you got it didn't you
and so um
and so uh i go to the bathroom and i'm
pissing and it's one of those things
that's like a uh it's got a urinal and
then it's got a [ __ ]
and i mean there in the bathroom is so
[ __ ] messy right it's a dueling piano
place there's like a [ __ ] there's
like a family of toads in the corner
and uh
and um
why is it so it's so [ __ ] gross in
bath and public bath it's like dude
and so uh
so i'm pissed and i look over a family
of toads is like bro i'm like yeah hey
guys and so um as i'm pissing i hear
behind me
these words
so you got married today
and i'm in my tux
and i'm pissing as i'm pissing i say
uh
yep i sure did
and as i'm saying yup i sure did
a different voice behind me says
nope not till next week
so now i realize
that i'm not even in this conversation
two guys are talking to each other
behind me
and i'm just holding my [ __ ]
so i lo so then the guy who says no not
till next week looks at me and says oh
you did and i'm like i got a [ __ ]
boutonniere on [ __ ]
there's a flower close to my chin what
do you think i fell off a cake
like wha of like come on that's the
ultimate work with me man
like just be like hey yeah dude i see
that i'm mine but now he's putting me
into i'm holding my [ __ ] looking over
like this and he's like oh you did and
i'm like yeah i didn't realize you guys
were talking to each other and he says
yep i'm getting married next week i said
and i say
and i say no [ __ ] congratulations man
and he says you too
and then the next thing he says is
i broke my foot today
and i say
really like like where like what is did
david lynch
[ __ ] construct this bathroom
and i look i look behind me i say oh
yeah and he says yup and i say oh [ __ ]
man well you know you're you're a
[ __ ] trooper i zip up
and i walk out and even wash my hands
because it's too weird and also my
cock's clean
so i leave
and i'm like this is so weird and i walk
out and i sit down and then i like i
want to think i actually broke his foot
and he walks out with no foot brace just
shoes on and he's limping so hard and
i'm just like hey dude go home
or to the doctor
but dude every i love weirdness bro i
love weird-ass [ __ ]
and we walked down the [ __ ] street
and there was a dude that was just like
yo bro you want a rose
and i was like nah you know don't ever
give me anything if i'm walking you know
you hold this i don't get all right and
he was like nah give it to her man and
i'm like okay and i took the rose and i
said hey baby look what i got for you
and she was like oh my god how nice and
then i look and the guy goes like this
and i'm like
where is this world you know
and santa barbara we walked all the way
back in santa barbara was you know and
then kristen like took off her heels and
she was like i'm just gonna walk
barefoot like there's i'm like baby
you're gonna get [ __ ] stuck with a
syringe and she's like no way i used to
do this all the time in college and i'm
like just can you put your heels on or
can i carry you you know cause i'm a
real man and she was like no i got it
don't even worry about it she's getting
her [ __ ] back to the room feet all
dirty and [ __ ] people came back to the
room there were [ __ ] people i didn't
even know we're there dude
uh
let's see what else the [ __ ] uh
david sullivan was there he said it
looked [ __ ] really good sitting the
way i was sitting he was like i never
tell you this but right now you look
really good i had my time done my chest
was out so it was [ __ ] ridiculous i
have a picture of it i told him take a
picture of it and your boy ended up
getting some sun dude it was 5 30 but
that santa barbara sun beating on my
head dude and i still got it dude you're
probably trying to adjust the hue on
your [ __ ] television screen but dude
turns out your boy got some sun when it
was 5 30 talking about his vows dude so
we had a good time
we had a good time
so that's that's it man
and um you know
cal's talking dude
kyle's talking a lot and it's great
uh
i walked down the street and [ __ ] the
other day this was in santa barbara
santa barbara is insane and this guy
like every now and then
cinderella was like a place where a lot
of people were coming up to me i don't
know what it is that's my demo but like
this dude i was walking down the street
and some dude i was just like i'm gonna
go get some [ __ ]
i don't know everyone i was hungry right
and i saw this this pasta place and i
was like this is what i want but then
they had zucchini pasta i was like this
is what i want and also it keeps it
healthy
and so this guy looks at me before i
walk into the pasta place and i can tell
he's gonna say something he just goes
like this
right anytime a guy looks at you like a
[ __ ] meerkat and you're a little bit
famous you're like here he comes and
he's just like
and and i i don't look i go straight
because
if you dance with him a little bit it's
sometimes awkward and i understand how
that could make me by the way somebody
came up to me today and they're like i
know you hate when fans come up with you
to come up to you and i and i don't hate
that
but come correct
i don't hate that at all
but this is a transaction let's get it
done in fact i don't hate it i love it
but come correct right
so i got this meerkat looking at me from
across the street and i'm like let me
just dip into this pasta place get some
zucchini pasta so i get it
and i see the guy waiting outside of the
[ __ ] zucchini pasta place and i'm
like great
now i gotta have pressure while i eat
but i'm not gonna go back outside cause
what if he just wants to stare
i mean i do the thing sometimes where i
jump the gun and i'm like you want a
picture and they're like nah bro and i'm
like
no i
it's oh i
i know
so i'm chilling in the pasta place
waiting for my food
and then he comes in and he says hey man
i say what's up and he says dude what
are you doing here
and i'm like i'm just gonna probably eat
some pasta and he was like yeah but like
you have a show out here and i was like
nah actually just chilling because i
don't want to get in i'm saying get
married and then he's like oh really and
we got to talk so long right
grateful for the dude that he knows who
i am but
and he goes like this ah cool man well
like i
i love your stuff man i'm a big fan i
say oh thanks so much dude and he says
you want to do my podcast
and i'm just like
everybody's got a [ __ ] okay
everyone's got a [ __ ] podcast then
huh
[ __ ] dead people have podcasts now
it's like the podcast of napoleon robin
they they're like we've reincarnated
napoleon and also we've reincarnated a
regular guy there's just so many they're
a duo that has a podcast now
napoleon and frank
hey napoleon how was it invading
everybody giving them [ __ ] leprosy
hey
[Music]
don't you like talk regular
[Laughter]
napoleon and frank
they both used to be dead now they have
a podcast
so i'm just like
he says you want to do my podcast and i
[ __ ] literally said
no
but i'll take a picture with you and he
was like oh dude
you know what i don't have a phone
[Laughter]
hey guy
you want a podcast
step one
have a phone
the guy goes like this oh dude i don't
have a phone
then how do you have a podcast
how does santa barbara exist is what i'm
saying it's like [ __ ]
fantastic beasts and where to find them
this is where you find them in santa
barbara
there were some fantastic beasts
it's unbelievable dude
so
anyway if you want to do a podcast just
wander around state street a little bit
and that guy will come up to you and
then he like wrote me the other and he's
like verified i'm like oh i'm an [ __ ]
i don't know what was he doing in santa
barbara dude it's crazy i could just
have a podcast and be successful in a
place like [ __ ] santa barbara or
wichita
what wichita the murder capital bbbtk
every time someone says the bt killer i
think of that [ __ ] b2k group
i don't even know what they sang was
omarion on that who was on that
am i racist
i'm sorry little kids but i'm gonna kill
a clown today
um
so what else happened dude
this is great man
all right we're back it got hot as [ __ ]
i had to let the air in do it i was
gonna faint man um
it's uh i was just thinking about the
world man while i was going to the
bathroom
uh well you know sometimes i like
talking about news on this on this
podcast you know i like doing a little
bit i always kind of try and do a little
bit of stuff that happened to me and
then also like some news and [ __ ] and i
do like doing miss connections and stuff
but like i don't like talking like
politics and [ __ ]
and so much of the [ __ ] that's happened
lately is politics like ukraine and the
[ __ ] kids dying on with their with
the gun control and all that [ __ ]
and like i don't want to talk about that
[ __ ] you know you come here for real
issues
you know you come here for the
hard-hitting [ __ ]
like what pants to wear and how it feels
when somebody is waiting for you outside
of a [ __ ] zucchini
pasta place
and um
that's why we say [ __ ] npr you know
so like every now and then there's a
political thing that happens that i
gotta talk about and this week it's
biden
fallen off of the bicycle dude
this is the whole thing i always said
when i was a kid
i said there should be one
uh more
uh rule
on having your driver's license
you should and this has nothing to do
with the biden thing but
it kind of does in at the end of it
you have to be able to catch a ball
that's it
if someone throws you a ball and they
can underhand it but you have to be able
to catch it if you can't catch it you
can't operate a car you can't operate a
bicycle you just can't you gotta stop
doing that right okay and what this does
is it weeds out the people who are gonna
[ __ ] kill people by mistake
it weeds out people that are gonna crash
in you it weeds out people that are
gonna [ __ ] drive off a cliff for by a
mistake
they're gonna be operating a forklift
and spear somebody right
this is the thing after 60 there has to
be a universal test across the whole
planet and it's to throw a ball test
it's to throw me a ball test you got to
stand there
and you got it somebody's going to be
you know five feet away from you and
they throw your ball you get two chances
if you can't catch them all two times
that's it
you gotta walk everywhere or be a
passenger
and you can't operate heavy machinery
joe biden there's no way this
[ __ ] would pass this pass a ball
test
so he shouldn't be on a bicycle
this guy fell
harder than dodge coin
this guy do it let's watch him i got it
on screen
it's a [ __ ] not moving at all so
nervous
can't get his foot out of the pedal
dude it's a [ __ ] when you're constant
and you're not moving just like this
[ __ ] with the helmet has to do it
because he's president needs to be a
[ __ ] role model
spit the helmet now
all good you're 80.
get off the bike
not like that get off the bike don't
ever get on the bike
promoting health promoting safety
[ __ ] with the helmet
fell got up said he's okay
defensive oh now
smitch and sidney francivo that's our
president
how look i'm not politically charged
vote for whoever the [ __ ] you want i
don't care i got friends that voted for
trump close friends and i have friends
that voted for biden close friends
i don't give a [ __ ] i buy yeezys even
though kanye's a lunatic
i i i don't care i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't do the thing well i i buy new
balance because i had a new balance why
people tried to pressure [ __ ] steph
curry to not
work with him because they voted for
trump and he's not spoken about trump i
don't give a [ __ ] dude if the shoe's
nice
the kid's getting it
but the president has to be able to
catch a ball
or he's gonna lay off the bikes you know
and it's fine but it's like dude this
guy can't catch a break poor guy you
know
poor guy fell hard i'm surprised he
didn't i'm surprised honestly he didn't
die my grandma my great grandma we used
to call her super grandma we would laugh
so hard i don't know why we called her
super grandma but we used to walk in and
[ __ ] make her put her arms up like
this she was flying never saw her bottom
half because she always had a blanket
over it and we'd be like do super
grandma and she put her arms like that
we'd fall so hard and then one day she
fell down the stairs broke her hip and
died that's a death sentence if you're
[ __ ] 80 you fall down you break your
hip that's a death sentence dude i have
no idea why but if you break your hip
you die that's what happens but if
you're 100 you'll break a hit hip
instant death
joe biden's 80 can't believe he didn't
break [ __ ] maybe he didn't they're
trying to cover it up i'm not a
conspiracy theorist but you know
i still think he's a hologram honestly
on his bicycle look at this this is from
at this point i think what happens is he
takes his left foot off as you can see
he thinks his right foot is out of the
saddle clearly it's not he goes to step
down why is it this is a from first of
all this is from it says president joe
biden falls off his bike this is the
first youtube video i clicked it's from
boxing now
pick a lane
also why is boxing why is boxing now
commenting on joe right on his but joe
biden on joe riding on his bike joe
biden on his bike joe biden riding on
his bike joe ryan on his bike
and uh also why is there commentary on
it dude i hate when you can't get the
[ __ ] video dude you just wanna see
joe biden fall down and some guy's like
and that's where he did it i think it's
because now now let's sit now here we
are at the round table why did yo it's
like dude
pulling him to the ground
obviously pretty scary for someone that
age to fall like that
but obviously he's he's up he's talking
to people by the way he's walking into a
little girl there in the crowd and
things seem to be going it's fine after
that
the white house chimed in their press
secretary said that he was i mean this
is not it's boxing now you know not news
we talked to the white house the white
house chimed in and said that it's not a
big issue it's going to be fine now back
to talking about evander holyfield
that's it for the episode here on
youtube if you want to catch the rest of
the episode the uncut version the raw
rough rugged and raw uncut version go on
over to our patreon.com crystalia
patreon.comcrystalia for only six
dollars you can get all of the complete
episodes and also there's an extra
episode a month
and there's like 14 by now maybe 15 so
you can go binge those six bucks a month
sign up today patreon.com chrisley
there's also more there's more too
all right guys take care
[Music]
you